whatever doesn't kill you only makes you
stronger stranger things too so I have
seen the first four episodes on calling
it a night for that and I want to talk
about them so far if I might still have
stuff around my eyes
it's Halloween as I'm recording this so
give me a break on that but stranger
things - heads up spoilers for these
first four episodes I'm not holding back
I've got my retrospective up on the
first season so you you shouldn't you
should see you at least these first four
episodes before you come into this video
so there's a lot to like here the
returning cast all great they were great
in their roles before they're great in
their roles again pretty much across the
board most of the new cast I'm enjoying
I'm actually really liking Paul Reiser
basically sort of replacing Matthew
Modine as the head of the science
facility place government thing and I
really like that for a couple of reasons
the first is one of the weaknesses of
the first season was Matthew Modine not
so much the performance but the way the
character was written and shot and
portrayed which was that he was just
sort of this ominous scientist guy he
didn't have any personality one thing
you cannot accuse Paul Reiser of is
lacking in personality now whether you
like that personality or not I know some
people really can't stand him I kind of
liked the guy anyway we just another
reason that this works for me I find he
has an inherent kind of charm which i
think is a really fun sort of
juxtaposition when he's in this kind of
position where he like I don't think
it's okay for me to trust you
and yet I kind of find him inherently
affable and I'm actually finding the
entire government science facility thing
to be way more nuanced than it wasn't
the first season in the first season
they were pretty much clear-cut the bad
guys here they're not necessarily coming
across as good guys and they still come
across as dangerous and potentially a
problem but it's established basically
first thing we see them doing in regards
to you know the
side-down sort of bleeding into our
dimension is burning it away fighting it
back so it becomes a question of huh are
they a necessary evil because they are
beating this thing back they're still
running experiments who knows what
they're gonna do with that kind of
information they're obviously willing to
go to extreme lengths to keep this thing
a secret so they're not good but do we
need them anyway and that I think is is
way more interesting than just the
flat-out here's the evil scientist which
we had in the first season so digging
all of that I also like Shawn acid and I
can sum up him in literally two words
adorably lame I think he's great he's
wonderful in this um max I'm digging I'm
digging her performance and I'm digging
her character I think there's some
issues with the way she is being used
and implemented at least as far as I am
in the show but I'm gonna come back to
that so there are because I'll be honest
there there I've got a lot of nitpicks
and unfortunately the negatives are kind
of in the forefront in my mind and I
kind of feel like I want to talk about
them the most I'm trying to focus on the
positives initially though because I
don't want this to be as negatively
tinged a video as I'm afraid it's gonna
end up becoming once I started talking
about my nitpicks and my gripes and and
all of those things but you know the
kids are still great the dynamic between
the kids is awesome and these young
actors are all really good I Elevens
relationship with hopper I find to be
pretty interesting I'm a little mixed on
what's going on with eleven so I guess
I'll also come back to that the effects
are still great I love the just you know
the shadow demon creature thing I it
feels very much of the same world as the
demagoguing but obviously it's bigger
and it's got its own deal going on
whatever it is but I like I think that's
a really lovely stark visual that whole
thing overall the show is good the
writing is good the presentation is good
but yeah I've got I've got a lot of
nitpicks
and so the the one
new cast member who as of this recording
I'm not digging and that is Max's
brother whatever he is what I don't like
about him right now is he at least so
far appears to be the generic eighties
movie bully that last season I'd been
afraid Steve was gonna be and he turned
out not to be so that was a pleasant
surprise for me in this case he's he
really appears to just be that and I
don't like that archetype and I am NOT
interested in that as a character so
since I mentioned max I feel I'm
irritated at the ways in which the show
is kind of keeping her out of the group
and because it feels very forced it
feels artificial because her dynamic and
her chemistry wind them is quite good
and I just I feel like the show's going
in I feel like the show is regretting
introducing her as early as it did and
maybe things would have worked better if
we only saw the name on the arcade
machines in the first episode only
actually met her in the second she only
started interacting with the boys
directly in the third and then you
started integrating her into the group
in the fourth I feel like they move
things too fast and now they're like
trying to go away she can't actually be
part of a group hold her back which also
feeds into one of my things about 11 so
11 again the actress great she's still
playing the part wonderfully I'm really
liking the way that she appears to be
getting a handle on her abilities both
the telekinesis and the reaching out to
people others she just finds white noise
and covers her eyes and reaches out I'm
loving all that and I always love the
visualization of that it looks terrific
but there's a couple of things about her
character that I don't like right now
and one of them is the one of the few
things that I'm gonna complain about
where I feel I can't point to a go that
was just a bad call and was the wrong
thing to do because admittedly most of
the things I'm gonna complain about at
least as far as characters and the way
characters behave and act all the many
stuff that my complaints are
that doesn't make sense because in every
case I understand why these characters
are behaving the way that they are and
it makes sense it is justified but I
still don't like it I still don't like
seeing these characters do these things
so that becomes arguably a matter of
personal taste and a lot of the things
I've got to say and a little bit kind of
fall under that this first thing about
11:00 though I don't think does and that
is that I don't like that she's still
speaking in this very broken truncated
version of English is imported meat
Tarzan you Jane kind of way of speaking
and I don't buy it
I don't buy it because at this point
it's been almost a year and we've seen
her in flashbacks we've seen the way
that Hopper interacts with her the way
that he speaks story speaks were very
conversationally he reads her stories
and books that you cannot tell me that
she has not gotten a better handle on
the English language by now just by
being around him and absorption and
she's watching TV yeah ya know at this
point you know she's older she looks
different she's got longer hair she
should not still be talking like that
the other thing with eleven because this
size into max and that is I really when
that scene happens after 11 has gotten
out of the cabin and she gets to the
school and she looks through the window
and there's Mike and there's Mac says
she sees Mike's smile and 11 gets this
serious look on her face and she makes
Mac's fall off the skateboard and I'm
sitting there going no no no no no no no
no cuz I just I want this I don't want
to see the characters do this and I get
it it makes sense I absolutely
understand and feel it is justified bad
eleven is behaving this way but I don't
want to see it I don't I have no
interest in this particular angle in
this jealousy thing I I don't care about
seeing this sort of thing from these
characters which all which then leads me
to Dustin
again the kid is playing him very very
well he's wonderfully fun to be around
but the whole thing with him and
d'Artagnan the little lizardy thing well
he's being dumb and I don't like
characters that I enjoy acting stupid
I don't enjoy watching them be dumb it
worked up to a point when he first found
this thing you know he had no he had no
idea what it was being no reason to
believe that it was dangerous once he
found out that it was from the upside
down the fact that he you know finds it
again is still hiding it from his
friends that ah that is bugging me cuz
he's dumb he's doing something dumb and
again don't tell me it makes sense that
he's doing it because bla bla bla but I
get it I don't question the motivations
that I get why he is doing this and I
understand the behavior and it makes
sense but I still I still don't like
hurt and I don't just mean in a
character isn't acting the way I will
behave like I I literally do not enjoy
watching him be dumb that is not
entertaining to me I'm hoping now that
the friggin thing has the demagogy mouth
going and it ate that cat that maybe
he'll wake the hell up oh why you get to
circle back to something that I do like
I am liking Nancy and John I'm liking
them for a number of reasons I'm liking
a that they are using barb and barbs
death as a way to really move and
motivate Nancy especially as a character
so that Barb's death now has much more
of the weight that it lacked in the
first season and that feels nice that
feels like a good thing to happen
and I'm also liking the direction that
where where she and John are going and
they appear to be prepared to take down
as best as they are able to this
facility in the scientists I'm on and
honestly this may be dumb but it's not
something that I know for certain as a
viewer is a stupid thing it's a ballsy
thing and a potentially dangerous thing
but like that I can admire as opposed to
Dustin
hiding dart from his friends that I'm
just like dumb I feel really bad for
will as a characters like this kid
cannot catch a break he was abducted he
was stuck in the upside-down for a while
and now he's got that friggin thing like
in him kind of sorta not entirely sure
what the deal is with that but I'm
really interested in that the whole
creature the whole shadow creature thing
I'm really really diggin that but I
think if there's part of me that wonders
because there's other nitpicks that I
could bring up and get into but I think
I've done enough but if I were to braid
to sort of a central here's the main
thing the first season had that this
season doesn't and maybe everything else
kind of circles around that the first
season had a really strong central
narrative focus that was the
disappearance of will buyers happens in
the first episode and everything builds
off of that because this whole town is
invested in this disappear kit that's
how Hopper gets involved
that's the accounts for Joyce and its
family that's all the other kids eleven
is tied to that everything is centered
around this one event and it is a strong
easily understood thing missing kid and
everything builds around that really
solid central pillar the second season
right now doesn't have that and four
episodes in it I'm feeling the lack of a
central focus and right now it is much
more a case of hey here are the
characters from the first season kind of
meandering their way through things that
are connected to the previous season so
you know we've got will initially just
dealing with visions the nightmares that
that has ramped up and maybe eventually
you know that shadow thing is gonna
become the new central pillar but four
episodes in I don't feel like there is
one so I mean there's that going on
eleven is fine and she's alive but she's
not being actively hunted so that's not
really moving the plot in and of itself
right now
Dustin finds dart but that have
the very end of the second episode and
it doesn't become cleared exactly in
what way that is going to be a threat
until until the latter half of the
fourth episode so that isn't really
driving the plot very much either now I
want to be clear it doesn't feel like
the show is spinning its wheels and not
going anywhere it just feels like there
is a lack of clear focus for both the
characters and the story as a whole that
the first season was able to build
really strongly around disappeared kid
and I think the lack of that is is my
main thing when comparing this to the
first season and I think a lot of the
other things I've noticed because I
didn't I didn't have time to go back and
binge through season one again before
the new season came out and there's part
of me that suspects that there's
probably maybe not as many but a fair
number of similar nitpicks that I
probably would have of that first season
but they've either faded with memory or
I may not have even noticed them at the
time because that strong central focus
was there when it's not there I pay more
attention to the individual threads and
the way that they're folding out and I
pick up on the things that don't work
for me a lot more if there isn't like a
real strong central thing for me to put
most of my focus on where I can go okay
maybe that thing's not great but this
central thing is awesome and season two
is kind of lacking that right now it's
just got the various you know threads
that are out there some better than
others and maybe as they come together
in the back half of the season they will
form a proper central focus but that
first season had one right off the bat
and this season kinda lacks it but I
want to be clear I am enjoying this show
and if it was not so late
I would watch more episodes I'm enjoying
the heck out of it I am looking forward
to watching the rest and coming back and
giving my opinion on the back half of
the season as well as the show overall
so that'll be it I am enjoying it I have
my nitpicks overall I feel the first
season was better if for no other reason
had a stronger central hook at the right
off the bat and I am hoping that this
will come together in a way that also
the first season did because I thought
found the first season really really got
going about three four episodes in and
this one might be starting to get there
so maybe it's just taking it a little
longer we'll see in any case first four
episodes of stranger things - have you
seen them what did you think about them
please no spoilers in the comments don't
be a jerk
but anything else you want to say drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also on half of
the punch like a girl podcast and that
is a presentation of the fire and water
podcast network
Fire & Water podcast comm and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]